pour serrer la main trop en faire non
plus ça va on a tellement peur libérant
nigeria petit baby ping en plus voilé
composite était au truc
le film saisit
youtube en avoir beaucoup trop docile
j'écoute son parti défendent maintenant
par urban nature on va je l'espère doit
descendre la barre de trop tout st
pierre s'est fait peur en trop sur l'
usine coran passe voilée on va mettre
des contraintes être me met le lucide
et le bleu et or seront très serrés sur
les ide derrière avec en épaisseur le
prince laurent s'est dès maintenant les
seins ou en mettant les pensées des
passoires gauche et l'autre toujours là
bref mettrait le feu lui au contraire le
car voilà d'abord voilà quand elles sont
rouges comme un bouchon dans l'écran
mais bon
et là tu vas être en la matière tout le
temps et pour un bon
3 bien d'en rendre bien dedans ça vient
dans le dans la matière de logement
on sait bien centré sur le projet le
secteur est bien voir qu'il est bien le
plus à gauche voilà
le bien le plus à gauche
c'est quoi c'est qu'on valait rien du
tout plu à ce qu'on prend pas vraiment
un petit peu l'important les soutiens
dans le spot sur lequel sa prise n'a pas
pris la tête
à tulle sais pas lequel tout en moi je
suis vraiment dans les ide derrière dans
le feu là
adieu
parce qu on saura en 128 voilà que
revient pour sa part le patin j'espère
pour tous sera peut être eu un sur dix
pensent heures dispensées en europe
orientale à bâtir je le sentais un peu à
gauche fort bien conduit à ce pauvre de
l'ensemble je pense qu'on va le quitter
le truc très bien tout va la gauche bien
on en mangerait pas ceux restés sur
l'est c'est pas un peu pensé conférence
initiée par cette agence la grèce que
gbagbo
le parisien annonce la pauvreté
monétaire
ma mère a alors fait